>>Joe Malin: Hello everyone and welcome once
again to Android Developer Office Hours. My
name is Joe Malin. I'm your Moderator. Next
to me is Trevor Johns and then down the line
in his official Android worker's hat is Dan
Galpin. Our engineer today is Dan Pham. We
have some great questions here today, but
I also encourage you to come into our Hangout
or type in your questions as well. We've got
lots of time to do that today. We're bringing
up Hangouts as quickly as we can so bear with
us. Meanwhile, we'll hop into our first question
on Moderator, and that is, gentlemen--
>>Joe Malin & Dan Galpin: Should your apps
store all
>>Joe Malin: data that's not sensible in /sdcard
as /data is quite small on some phones? But
on the other hand data in /sdcard on the Galaxy
Nexus ends up in /data/ and personally I'd
prefer /data. What's the best way to handle
this?
>>Trevor Johns: I'm a little confused about
what he means about /data versus /data/ 'cause
that's the same path. I'm wondering if what
he means is that information stored on /sdcard
on Galaxy Nexus is still stored somewhere
inside of /data because the device doesn’t
have a external sd card.
>>Joe Malin: Right
>>Trevor Johns: So I'm not, I'm not sure where
else you'd put the data in that case, but
>>Dan Galpin: I, I assume what he means in
this case is that /sdcard/Android/data is
the only, I mean it's the only place that
that is where it could actually end up getting--
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: stored and even it's ah, the
only, the only real difference is on Galaxy
Nexus is one of them has a case dependent
[inaudible] and the other one doesn't, uh,
and one of them is of course accessible to
other applications, so and you know and uh
I think that if it's sensitive data as a general
rule, you want to avoid storing it on the
sd card. If you're storing a lot of data,
you know the sd card is safer you know and
then the real question is how do you detect
a device like Galaxy Nexus which is using
contiguous storage between both and that is
that is kind of an interesting question. You
know as a general rule, you know we don't
really suggest actually using a different
approach based upon the different devices,
but you know the goal you know going forward
it's really, really nice to have devices where
it's all one file system. Like Galaxy Nexus
you don't have to actually worry about this
and it's kind of a nice benefit of the design.
I don't know, any, any comments on, on best
practice around that Trevor? Is there a way
to detect whether or not you have a con, have
a single file system or multiple?
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, well, you can check
the external storage state, which would tell
you whether or not there's actually an sd
card mounted or available.
>>Dan Galpin: Mm-hmm.
>>Trevor Johns: That being said, I usually,
you know I think the rule is just look at
what type of data it is, like Dan said, if
it's something that's small and/or sensitive,
it's usually best to place it inside of in
the apps' private you know tree within /data.
If it's large and/or publicly or should be
publicly accessible, then you should put it
on the sd card regardless of whether or not
that's a real sd card or not. And then the
really the only other thing you have to watch
out for is the case where there's not an sd
card present. So you know a device that uses
external storage but the user's removed the
sd card, in which case you really only have
one choice, which is internal storage or I
suppose you could refuse to run, but let's,
let's avoid that possibility. Normally you
want your app to run. But, yeah, I think just
you know looking at the use case, where, what
type of data you're storing will dictate where
you store it and regardless of whether or
not it’s actually a real sd card or not
shouldn't make a difference.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, this the real question
is the word is in the, in the question is
sensible and I'm not sure if we mean.
>>Joe Malin: I think he means sensitive there.
>>Dan Galpin: I don't know, that's what I
was, I was, because sensible in terms of in
terms of large data you know would make sense.
So you know large data you know generally
you want to put on the sd card. Sensitive
you know data you want to put on in the data
space. So I guess that's that's the best we
can do there. So, so, so Galaxy Nexus though,
will it always show up as an sd card mounted
or will it never show up as an sd card mounted?
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, that's a good question.
I want to say they'll show up as mounted because
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: that's how you determine whether
or not you can actually even attempt to write
it there.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: So it should show up as always
mounted.
>>Dan Galpin: Right, right. That's what I
thought, ok.
>>Trevor Johns: Now you do also have to watch
out that if the user is using an older device
that uses a you know FAT file system for external
storage, in other words it's using an sd card,
when the user connects the device to the computer
and turns on USB storage, even though the
sd card is still attached, it'll become unmounted
as far as your application is concerned. So
it is possible for the sd card to disappear
even when it's inserted in the device.
>>Dan Galpin: Now, do you--
>>Trevor Johns: So on older devices it is
a it is a lot more common than I think a lot
of developers realize.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah. And if you actually have
a file handle open on that sd card, it will
Android will immediately terminate your application,
so if when, when, when the sd card is unmounted,
so that's the other the other the other side
of using it.
>>Joe Malin: Ok? Thank you gentlemen. Our
next question is: "My activity has a spinner
in the action bar, each spinner item corresponds
to a fragment. I have a use-case where if
I select an item from one fragment I have
to replace the current fragment with another
fragment. How do I manage the back stack?"
>>Trevor Johns: Ok. So, I'm not sure if it
really even matters whether or not there's
a fragment there or not, I think the big question
is here is what's the correct user experience?
And when it comes to something like a spinner
in the action bar, I like to think of this
as similar to tabs at the top. And if you
look at pretty much every system application
that uses tabs, when you switch tabs, back
doesn't take you back to the old tab, it'll
take you back to the previous activity, which
you know in many cases means just right out
of your application assuming this is your
home screen and so I think with a spinner
the paver should be the same, so when you
switch tabs, don't change what's in your back
stack and for those of you who don't have
a lot of experience with fragments, whenever
you do a fragment transition, it's up to the
developer to determine what the new state
of the back stack should be, so in this case
it would just be as simple as not doing anything
to the back stack. Leave it as is. Whatever
was in there previously will still be your
previous entry and when you hit back you'll
go to that.
>>Dan Galpin: And the more interesting question
is, is, is the question with you know you
have you have a fragment and you click on
something in one fragment and it replaces
that fragment with another fragment and and
my assumption on this one, oohh, nice, my
assumption in this one is that if we actually
are again having two methods of switching
between these fragments, one that's that's
using spinners and one that's using the you
know being able to click on one fragment and
replace it, it probably makes sense to not
put it on the back stack if it is you know
feeling again like a transition to a completely
different state, then it may make sense and
I think that's, that one's, the only thing
that's tricky at that point is, you know,
what happens to those spinners in the action
bar? Are you actually changing the state of
the action bar to disable those spinners at
that point? And again there's just not enough
information in this question to give a really
thorough answer, but I think, I think again
it ultimately comes down to the user experience.
As far as managing the back stack itself,
you know, you obviously, it's it's fairly
straight forward to assign IDs to the various
fragments, and you can actually you know very
easily look to see whether that fragment is
currently in the back stack, you can pull
it out of the back stack, there's a lot of
stuff in fragments, actually, to manage it,
but you know in this case we're really talking
about the user experience rather than you
know the kind of mechanics of it.
>>Trevor Johns: Right. And I think a good
example if you need something to look at what
correct behavior would be, would be Gmail.
So Gmail has a spinner in the action bar,
it has a lot of different activities, a lot
of different states, and so add two Google
accounts to your phone, fire up Gmail and
play around, right? You'll notice if you do
switch accounts and you hit back, it doesn't
switch back to the other account, it doesn't
count that as a state change, but if you,
you know if you open a message and go back,
that does. Now when you do open a message,
the spinner disappears and it gets replaced
with the action bar is updated to reflect
your new context which is viewing a message
rather than viewing your account list in your
message list. So a lot of subtle details there
you need to take into account, but I think
that's a good example.
>>Dan Galpin: Uh-huh.
>>Joe Malin: Ok. Thank you gentlemen. Next
question: "I'd like to put a ViewPager on
half of a two-pane layout. Can I put a ViewPager
in a fragment, and more fragments in that
ViewPager? I'd like my left pane to hold swipe-able
lists, and the right pane to contain details
of list items that are clicked."
>>Dan Galpin: So this is one of those cases
in which I would say that it's not strictly
necessary to use a fragment. And in fact you
know as a general rule our, our dev team tries
to discourage people from putting fragments
within fragments. You know the goal, that's
really what views are intended for. You know
the fragment really is, is, is the idea of
a fragment is usually to maintain some state
you're gonna be showing in two different,
in two different kind of application states,
whether that is you know alone and by itself,
in a full screen view that's gonna have an
activity and a fragment stack associated with
it or if it's going to be in you know a side-by-side
like tablet layout. It's trying to take those
pieces and turn them into reasonable components.
In this case I think it's almost always a
better idea to actually just use the view
hierarchy itself, the actual, pager actually
does not, ViewPager actually can be done without
any fragments at all. It works quite well
just with views, ergo ViewPager, and that's
how I would do it. I don't think there's any
particular advantage in using a fragment here.
>>Trevor Johns: Now let's say that you still
have some reason that you want to do this.
There are some caveats that you should be
aware of from a technical perspective. If
you try and display a fragment or a ViewPager
inside of a fragment which contains another
ViewPager, FragmentManager can get a little
bit confused about how to resolve all of that
when you do a transition and from what I've
heard, even though I've never tried to do
it myself, you can, you know the solution
would be to make sure that you don't set your
ViewPager's adapter until after the first
transition is completed. And that's as simple
as making [inaudible] an async task or a handler,
something like that, just making sure that
it's delayed a bit and then by the time you're
rendering that, the second fragment, the first
fragment's already there. Again, though, you
probably don't want to be doing this.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah. I mean you can definitely
put, you know, ViewPager, you know, inside
of a fragment, and you can certainly put whatever
you want inside of that ViewPager. You know
the real tricky thing is of course when you
get into these multiple ViewPager states and
there is some mechanism that's actually in
JellyBean that actually does handle some of
this, unfortunately it's not, which, which
allows it to actually track the scrollability
of an internal window, which allows a lot
of, like if you have ViewPager within ViewPager
you can actually do stuff like scroll to the
end of one and then have it once it's finished
scrolling it'll actually scroll to the next
in the primary ViewPager, stuff like that,
but none of that is actually available in
you know the default [inaudible] that you're
gonna use for across all the different Android
versions, so there's some work if you want
that kind of that kind of experience. Again,
from your question, it sounds like you're
more interested in just having a ViewPager
inside of, inside of a fragment, and that's
fine.
>>Joe Malin: Ok.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, and so Daniel's telling
me that we finally have Hangouts up, so for
those of you who are joining live, feel free
to hop on. For those of you who are joining
us for the first time today, just as a reminder
for everyone else, you are certainly welcome
to go in to hop on to our Hangout and ask
us questions live, we'd love to hear from
you. And if your question's already in the
Moderator queue, feel free to hop on too.
A lot of times we can ask you for more details
and it's just we can give you a better answer
if you're on here to have a discussion with
us.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: So we do have a limit, ten
people at a time, so try to make sure that
you're only joining the Moderator or I'm sorry
if you're only joining the Hangout if you
have a question to ask just to make sure we
keep those slots open and for those that,
for everyone else, feel free to watch the
live stream either on YouTube or developers.google.com,
plus you get a better picture if you're watching
the YouTube version than the Hangout version.
So YouTube for watching, Hangouts for live
questions and definitely hop on and ask us
questions, we'd love to hear from ya.
>>Joe Malin: Agreed. Thank you. Thank you
very much. Next question: "To frequently sync
a database from the cloud into SQLite on Android,
should I use a background service activated
by a wakeup alarm, or a SyncAdapter? And if
I use the latter, for what do I need an account
(or do I really)?"
>>Trevor Johns: So that depends on the nature
of what you're syncing. It depends. If you
need, if you have account credentials you
don't necessarily need to implement an account,
it's entirely possible to go and place them
into a shared preferences file or something
like that. What we said earlier, make sure
your private data is actually being stored
on internal storage rather than the sd card,
make sure it's set to mode, mode private so
no other apps can access it, but you normally
don't need an account unless you're providing
authentication credentials to other other
services on the device. So for example if
you implement or if you want to talk to Google
Services, you can talk to the Google Account
and ask for an OAuth token. That's what account
manager lets you do. Now going back to your
original question, though, should you use
a background service or SyncAdapter? If you
use SyncAdapter, Android will periodically
go and sync your data on a schedule that it
determines. This is a good thing, 'cause it
makes sure the phone can do things like optimizing
for battery life, it's really bad to go and
have all sorts of different services syncing
at different times, 'cause that means it has
to wake [inaudible] up a lot. If it can go
and batch those into one big sync operation
across all apps on the phone, SyncAdapter
is great for that, it's good for your users.
That being said, if it's a fairly infrequent
task, or if you have some really odd semantics
that would prevent SyncAdapter from working
properly, you know background service works
perfectly fine. There's nothing wrong with
that other than like I said you don't get
the optimizations that SyncAdapter gives you.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah. I think, I think the real
question is 'cause he was trying to get the
latter, is do I need, do we need an account
in order to use SyncAdapter? That's, that's,
that's
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: I think that's the question
he was curious about.
>>Joe Malin: I would say that reading this
and knowing about how SyncAdapter is used
in things like ContactsProvider, my guess
is that he's asking things about an account
because Sample SyncAdapter, which is about
the only documentation we have for SyncAdapters,
uses OAuth tokens and the answer that I would
give in that context is that's not required,
it's there to show you how to use it, but
you don't have to use it.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Joe Malin: It's used there because Sample
SyncAdapter syncs to a Google service that
needs Authorization, and using the structure
that Sample SyncAdapter uses, you only have
to provide like an account name and a password
once and then an Authorization token to store
it.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Joe Malin: So you don't, that helps using
SyncAdapter, because SyncAdapter doesn't have
to be able to count on being able to go back
to the user.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, there are many open web
services that aren't gonna require account
information.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: And SyncAdapter is still a great
way to assure that the phone can kind of optimize,
the system can optimize for battery life.
>>Joe Malin: There's some, there are a lot
of things that SyncAdapter gives you for free.
As Trevor said, it schedules things automatically
at a good time, batches up things together,
it will also check to make sure it won't run
if you don't have network connectivity, so
you don't have to go off and test for yourself
that the network's available, SyncAdapter
will do that for you. So it's just a question
of how compatible your particular app model
is with what SyncAdapter does. I hope that
answers the question. Do we have anything
out there in Hangout land? No?
>>Dan Pham: Yeah, we sure do.
>>Joe Malin: Oh, good, super.
>>Dan Pham: I'm gonna put Jared on.
>>Joe Malin: Go ahead.
>>Dan Pham: One second. Jared, alright Jared,
you should be live, go ahead.
>>Joe Malin: Hey.
>>Trevor Johns: Hold on a sec, we don't actually
hear you.
>>Dan Pham: Hold on, yeah,
>>Joe Malin: Hold on.
>>Dan Pham: Hold on one second.
>>Trevor Johns: Try the red knob, Dan.
>>Joe Malin: Push the red button.
>>Dan Pham: [inaudible]
>>Trevor Johns: Red knob on the Hangout slider.
Alright, go ahead and try talking again.
>>Joe Malin: No.
>>Trevor Johns: See if speakers are on, speakers
are very on.
>>Dan Galpin: Yes, you're, you're gonna be
loud when we hear you.
>>Trevor Johns: Try hitting volume up, Dan,
on the Mac.
>>Joe Malin: Hello?
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, boy. Alright, we're experiencing
some technical difficulties, stand by for
a second. Is it muted?
>>Dan Pham: It is not muted.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, red slider is up,
red knob above Hangout is up.
>>Dan Pham: Yeah, we're all good.
>>Trevor Johns: Do you see any audio coming
in from the computer on the level satellite?
>>Dan Pham: Tweaking, some.
>>Trevor Johns: Try jiggling the cable going
to the speaker down from the board.
>>Dan Galpin: [laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: [laughs]
>>Dan Galpin: As you can see, Trevor is a
prime trouble shooter here.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Daniel Pham: Hmm.
>>Joe Malin: Hmm. Nope.
>>Dan Galpin: I was expecting some noise there.
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, we heard something. Try
talking again, let's see if we can hear you
now. No. Are you getting audio on the computer?
Like do you see his level indicator moving?
>>Dan Pham: Yes.
[static is heard]
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so the sound board's
working.
[buzzing sound]
>>Trevor Johns: Do you have the cables plugged
into the right ports? [laughs]
>>Joe Malin: Is it plugged in? Is it turned
on?
[buzzing noise]
>>Trevor Johns: Hit, hit the volume adjust
button and let's see if we get any audio?
>>Dan Galpin: These are all the same things
I do when I'm debugging.
[clicking noise]
>>Trevor Johns: Ah ha.
>>Dan Galpin: Ah ha. Alright. That's good.
>>Trevor Johns: Try talking now.
>>Jared: How about now?
>>All: Yeah!
>>Trevor Johns: We can hear you.
>>Dan Galpin: We have sound. Excellent.
>>Dan Pham: It only took two minutes.
>>Joe Malin: Cool, that's good.
>>Jared: So I'm having some trouble with a
spinner on my action bar.
>>Dan Galpin: Ok.
>>Jared: After using it for a certain period
of time it doesn't seem to matter how long,
there's no constant on how long or how many
interactions with the app, but basically what'll
happen is the spinner will stop working and
Android outside of my apps log cap will report
that the window's already focused and it's
ignoring the focus gain and I've seen this
all over StackOverflow, but I haven't seen
any answers that pertain to an actual spinner.
>>Joe Malin: Hmm.
>>Trevor Johns: And does it actually cause
any problems for your app or is it just messages
in log cap?
>>Jared: Well, the user input is ignored,
it doesn't even make it to the app.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok. Interesting.
>>Jared: Because the warning, it's Android
is reporting a warning, the tag is "input
method manager service" and it says "window
already focused, ignoring focus gain of [inaudible]
.Android internal view. And that, that occurs
in the system log pad. If I look in my apps
filter, it doesn't show up at all.
>>Dan Galpin: And what device are you on here?
Just out of curiosity what version and what--?
>>Jared: This is a Galaxy Nexus.
>>Dan Galpin: Ok.
>>Jared: JellyBean.
>>Dan Galpin: Ok. Hmmm.
>>Trevor Johns: That's a tough one.
>>Jared: The nearest I can tell is it happens
when I do a lot of changes to the data adapter
for the spinner. Like the specific thing is
the the spinner stores a bunch of locations
and if I delete locations and then reset the
data adapter to the spinner, after maybe three
or four of those it'll stop functioning. Or
if I use other views in the activity for a
while and then try and change on the spinner
it stops functioning.
>>Trevor Johns: Now, are you actually changing
out the spinner's adapter or are you just
telling it that the data has changed?
>>Jared: Well, I tried telling it just that
the data has changed, but that didn't seem
to actually reset the contents, so I'm actually
changing the adapter.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok. That that might be a hint
there then. Because when you're gonna change
the adapter there's a lot of work that goes
on under the hood to go and update everything.
It normally should be enough to make sure
the data is present in your adapter and then
telling the spinner that the data has changed.
That's that's the sort of the canonical way
to go and update anything that uses an adapter.
>>Jared: Could you repeat that? It broke up
a little bit.
>>Trevor Johns: Sorry, I was saying normally
you want to make sure you update your adapter
and then tell the spinner or whatever control
you are using that the data has changed. That's
sort of the canonical way to update any, anything
that is displaying the contents of an adapter
on Android. So, and my guess is your problem
has something to do with the fact that you're
changing the adapter out entirely. Now the
other problem is and how do we fix that so
that when you call data's cha--, when you
notify the data has changed, that update has
taken effect. And normally that should be
automatic. As soon as you call that method,
the update, you know the contents should change.
So it's something else going on there too.
>>Jared: So if I'm using a array list to back
the adapter and I change the array list, then
I should just tell, call notify data so that
it changes on the adapter?
>>Trevor Johns: That's correct.
>>Jared: And then so I need to register the
actual spinner with that, right? Or does that
automatically call, does that automatically
cause the spinner to update?
>>Trevor Johns: The spinner should update
as soon as your adapter has been updated.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, well the spinner it would
notify data set changed.
>>Jared: I think you have to register that.
>>Dan Galpin: Notify data set change is usually
when you're tied to a, tied to content, right?
>>Trevor Johns: That's true, that's true.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: So, so we're talking about,
so if you're not actually doing, generating
this from a content provider, then, then,
then notify set data set change is not gonna
do anything, 'cause it's gonna, it's gonna
notify the, the red shirt content listeners
and there aren't gonna be any content listeners
'cause there's no providers.
>>Jared: Right, which is exactly what I ran
into and I'd call it and nothing would happen.
>>Dan Galpin: Yes. Umm.
>>Trevor Johns: I wonder if it's possible
that you're actually making a copy of the
array when you try to update it and the adapter
still has a handle on the old one? Is it,
is it possible that might be happening somehow?
>>Jared: Well, I have a class that keeps track
of that array list and it will reorder things
in the list, remove things from the list,
add things to the list, and then after that
function returns is when I'm trying to update
the spinner.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok. So it probably should
still be the same copy then.
>>Jared: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Interesting.
>>Jared: So right now the only way I it works
most of the time except for after a little
bit, after a you know a certain amount of
interaction.
>>Trevor Johns: Right, but that's where, that's
where you change out, that's where you're
changing out your, your adapter, though, right?
>>Jared: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, so you really, you really
shouldn't have to go and change the whole
adapter, I think, I think that's definitely
not the right way to go. That's, first off
even ignoring the fact that this is breaking,
swapping an adapter is a a relatively heavy
operation and when you think about the way
it's supposed to work, your adapter normally
is tied to a SQL-like database. You know nothing
wrong with tying it to an array or anything
else, but you know normally they're tied to
a database and every time the database updates,
you're not gonna go and rebuild a whole new
adapter and update it, it should just update
in place, so.
>>Jared: So then how do I get the spinner
to update when I change the array list?
>>Trevor Johns: That's a good question. It
normally, my understanding was just updating
the array list should be enough. Dan's searching
on his phone there.
>>Jared: Do I need to go in and validate the
view maybe, or?
>>Trevor Johns: You shouldn't have to do that.
That's something that the spinner should do
itself.
>>Dan Galpin: Uh huh.
>>Trevor Johns: Are you finding
>>Jared: 'Cause that was the very first thing
I tried
>>Trevor Johns: anything [inaudible] over
there, Dan?
>>Jared: and it definitely didn't work.
>>Dan Galpin: Interesting. Yeah, I'd have
to, I'd have to go take a look at what what's
actually is going on in code. You know my,
my experience is, is that it should notifies
the data set changed, it's been awhile since,
'cause 'cause the problem is that data set
change is based on the content observer pattern
and the content observer pattern is…
>>Trevor Johns: I mean the way you know this
is architected, the spinner, that's your view,
should be independent, it shouldn't care what's
happening inside of your adapter, which is
your, you know which is responsible again
for, that's your data observer essentially,
actually, I believe, or is the data observer
the spinner? In any case, it's supposed to
be all compartmentalized, your view is independent
of what the adapter is doing and the adapter
should, you know as soon as there's any updates
to the underlying data model you're using,
your, your, your array, it should automatically
propagate those updates back up to the view.
And something, something fishy's going on
here with the between the interaction between
your array and your adapter. I think we need
to take a look at your code and see what you're
actually doing there.
>>Jared: Well, I'm, yeah I should probably,
probably get this on StackOverflow for you
guys to look at, but basically the pattern
is I have a class that manages a list. When
that class makes any changes to the list,
it notifies the activity and right now the
activity resets the adapter, which is obviously
incorrect, but
>>Dan Galpin: It technically should work,
I mean it's
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, it's still not the way
you normally should do it.
>>Dan Galpin: It's not the way you should
do it, but you shouldn't end up with this
problem, this seems like, it seems like you're
running into some sort of probably some arrays
case an issue where there's a there's a the
item that's focused is not actually getting
cleared correctly. It does sound like there's
some weirdness [inaudible]
>>Trevor Johns: It's a little odd too that
if you're navigating around your views
>>Dan Galpin: Uh huh.
>>Trevor Johns: and not interacting with the
spinner at all, that the spinner will suddenly
stop working.
>>Jared: Right, yeah, like we, we implemented
a sliding drawer type of view and if I, if
I use a view element in that drawer, then
the spinner completely stops working.
>>Trevor Johns: And this doesn't modify your
array at all, right? Your data's still the
same?
>>Jared: Correct. No changes to the data set.
I haven't even modified the array, the data
adapter. All I've done
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, so, so yeah, you're not
changing it there, so there's gotta be a second
issue at play. Yeah, I think we need to take
a look at your code. Something, it's probably
something very subtle. I mean your overall
approach here doesn't sound like it should
be causing this many problems.
>>Jared: Right. That's kind of what I was
feeling and I spent a week and a half trying
to find
[laughter]
>>Jared: this and I'm at wit's end trying
to figure out what is causing this issue,
so I, I'll post as much as I can on stack
overflow and hopefully it will be enough.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, thanks.
>>Trevor Johns: Just be sure to post a link
to the question in the comments, either, was
your question about this is not the question
earlier about a spinner right, this is you're
a different person?
>>Jared: I'm the one at the top of the chat,
but not on Moderator.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, ok. Post a link in, actually
chat's gonna get erased when we log out. Can
you put it as a question on our, the G+ link
for this? Or the G+
>>Jared: Yes.
>>Trevor Johns: If you go to Google+ you'll
see a post for this event, leave it as a comment
there and that'll stick around after the show
ends. Just so we can make sure we can find
your question after.
>>Jared: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: And then we can go ahead and
get you some more information offline.
>>Jared: Ok. That's good, thank you.
>>Trevor Johns: Yep.
>>Joe Malin: Thank you. Thank you for your
patience. Do we have anybody else out there?
No? Ok, we'll go back to Moderator here. "I
want to use an HDMI capture device to make
a demo/tutorial videos for my apps. Before
I in I, before I something in a capture device,
will HDCP prevent me from recording the HDMI
stream when the device is displaying my app?
Will results vary depending on the Android
device?"
>>Dan Galpin: So in in modern devices, we've
actually added the ability to have, the contents
are protected contents versus unprotected
content and I don't believe that there's a
lot of older devices that, that'll mirror
that don't have this flag, so your application
can actually choose to say that you're actually
at a protected stream, on, on, on with the
latest version. I'm like looking at Trevor
like I think that's right.
>>Trevor Johns: Sounds right to me yeah.
>>Dan Galpin: So as long as your app isn't
doing that you shouldn't have any issues with
HDCP. You know we regularly capture a video
on the Friday Review and on the App Clinic
on Friday as well, so I think that, I think
that's you know the real the real issue is
actually getting an HDMI capture device that's
going to work well with your Android device
is probably the, the larger issue there. And
you know, it's, it's, sometimes you know some
HDMI capture devices may not actually do a
complete negotiation of HDMI parameters so
we, we've run into that as an issue, so you
know beware. The EDID really does need to,
some of the Android devices really do need
to get a valid EDID coming back from the device
they're plugged into and not all capture devices
will actually present that. So that would
be my, my only, my only concern there. So
my suggestion is get, if you get a capture
device, make sure that you can return it because
you just, until you've actually tested it
against your specific device you're not gonna
really know whether or not it's gonna be able
to do that successfully.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, I think that pretty
much summarizes it. HDMI capture in general
is always sort of tricky. HDMI is a consumer
protocol. It wasn't really designed to be
easy to record and you're gonna find yourself,
it's not an Android specific thing, just the
nature of working with HDMI, you're gonna
find yourself fighting the system all along
the way as you're trying to record a source.
Unfortunately there's not a good consumer
replacement available out there. As far as
how we do it here in the studio, we convert
everything, cameras, tablets, you know everything
we can, we convert into HDSDI, and that's
a much easier format to work with. But like
Dan said, our HDSDI converter boxes still
have some trouble decoding the signal from
Android, and that's on the HDMI side and there's
tricks you can use to get around it. There's
some devices out there that will modify the
EDID and try and fix the negotiation bugs
we've run into, but it is, it is a bit of
work and be prepared to spend some time getting
things to give you a nice video signal. I,
I, I, I'm just gonna go and say curse the
people who made HDMI. [laughs] When it works
though, it works beautifully, when it works.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: But you'll be able to get
it, I'm sure. If you do need any links to
possible hardware, feel free to follow up
with us offline, we can give you some product
recommendations, probably not something we
should cover on the air, just because I don't
want to go mentioning a whole list of brand
names, but we'd be happy to help you offline
on a one by one basis, or a one on one basis
and let you know what hardware we use here.
>>Joe Malin: Ok. Great. Thank you. Anything
else, Dan?
>>Dan Galpin: Nope.
>>Joe Malin: No?
>>Dan Galpin: Enough from me. I'm looking
at the next question already.
>>Joe Malin: Ok, good, super. Let's "Could
you offer some tips about using ProGuard for
an app that references many libraries? I have
spent a lot of time on using ProGuard to no
avail. The primary errors are duplicate class
definitions and library classes depending
on program classes." Gentlemen?
>>Dan Galpin: So I mean I think the first
thing to do is make sure you are actually
starting with our ProGuard file, our ProGuard
configuration file, which we do ship as part
of the SDK and it's built, it's added into
every project that is created using the eclipse
tools. And that at least will make sure on
the Android side of things that you are leaving
the pieces unobfuscated that need to be left
unobfuscated. I think the, the trickier part
is you know what's going on in your specific
situation involving libraries, and I assume
we're talking here about just you know Java
libraries rather than library projects? My
experience is that library projects actually
work quite reasonable well with obfuscation
because ultimately they're just built into
the same jar and it's all one thing that's
obfuscated all together. I don't, in terms
of, what's interesting in the case of and
I think that's actually what you're gonna
want to do is make sure that all your libraries
are all statically bound into, into one jar
file and rather than trying to obfuscate the
jar file and then try to bind those into independently
into the into the Android file because otherwise
it's all gonna get shoved into one giant Dalvik
mess and your there on all of the obfuscated
names are going to collide. I think that might
be what's going on here. Again I haven't tried
to do this from the command link tools, but
that's that's my current theory, but again
you know if you statically link it into one
bundle, I think it will actually do what you
want it to do. Any comments there?
>>Trevor Johns: I, that's pretty much the
same thing I'd recommend. Otherwise make sure
you, there are some things that ProGuard just
has a very hard time optimizing around, especially
links between you know classes that are not
explicitly referenced or things like that
and sometimes you just have to tell ProGuard
to exclude those classes from being optimized,
but
>>Joe Malin: Alright.
>>Trevor Johns: But I mean it's gonna depend
on the specifics for your application, so
without seeing your source code, all we can
do is give you very general advice.
>>Joe Malin: Great. Thanks. Next question
is: "When taking pictures from the front camera,
I see the images flipped (mirrored). What's
the best way to handle it? And are there any
code samples to draw free lines on ImageView
(like the draw something app, but on an ImageView)?"
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, let's start with
the first question there.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: So the way camera the camera
flipping works if you are looking at a front
facing camera, Android will automatically
flip it. There are some notes about that in
the documentation and I don't believe there's
a way to override that behavior. Do you know
of any Dan?
>>Dan Galpin: No, not that I know of, I mean
the easiest thing to do of course is to implement
a matrisk, a matrix to unflip it
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: when you are displaying it,
and that's, that's pretty straight forward.
The second question is how do I draw lines
on to an ImageView? And the answer is, you
don't. But what you can do is you can actually
take and create a canvas that is using that
image as its base and then you can draw lines
onto that canvas and then you can put and
then you can get and that canvas can be based
on a bitmap and you can put that bitmap back
into an ImageView. So that's one way of doing
it. Another way of course is to create a custom
control that is that you could derive from
ImageView and that would be very similar.
The only difference is you're going to in
the on draw method you're gonna call the standard
ImageViews draw and then you're going to then
take that canvas and draw whatever else you
need on top of it. So I think both of those
are kind of reasonable approaches. It really
depends on the performance. One thing that's
interesting to note about drawing lines is
if you're talking about drawing lots and lots
and lots of line segments, especially in sort
of continuous lines or allowing the user to
kind of add draw onto something. If you're
using the built in line drawing contracts
you will see on accelerated canvases things
are gonna start getting pretty slow because
every single time you draw a line segment
and add it to that geometry you're actually
going to generate a new texture, so it might
be a case where you might want to experiment
with using an, a non-accelerated view or actually
do off-screen, off-screen drawing, both of
which will have approximately the same impact.
But definitely if you're talking about this
thing where you want to show sort of continuous
drawing you may want to play with that from
a performance perspective.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, and as far as actual
code samples, this is a pretty specific use
case, I'm not aware of any that overlay line
segments on top of a, an ImageView, but there
are several examples of drawing apps within
the SDK samples. I know there's one in API
demos, it's not gonna do line segments, but
it does do just points. You can take a look
at that and at least see how to go and render
things onto a bitmap and then you know go
and convert that to something more useable.
>>Dan Galpin: There's also
>>Trevor Johns: That's probably a good place
to start.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, there's also a pretty
good Android U on doing custom controls.
>>Trevor Johns: Wait, wait, we should, we
should clarify what that is.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: Android U, yeah I'm sorry, there's
a, in the, in the develop, there's a developer
guide which we refer to as
>>Trevor Johns: Developer Training.
>>Joe Malin: Developer Training.
>>Dan Galpin: Which we refer to internally
as Android U. Thank you. And in Developer
Training there is actually a very good section
on, segment on making custom controls and
it actually draws a pie chart that's animated
on, in WinView and it's pretty cool and so
that might also help. Not exactly drawing
lines, but it does involve drawing lines.
>>Trevor Johns: It involves drawing.
>>Dan Galpin: It involves drawing, yes.
>>Joe Malin: Right. It would seem to me that
you probably would want to have a custom control
if you really want to have something like
an ImageView or something like that as part
of a larger application. Whereas if you're
just trying to write an app that that you
take pictures and draw lines on top of it
you can probably get away with having some
sort of canvas and drawing lines on top of
that without necessarily having, having to
implement it using an ImageView.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah. It really depends on on
on how you want you want to end up creating
your screen.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: You know it's helpful sometimes
to have that that custom view. And again you
could have that image be a background for
your custom view,
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: it doesn't even have to be an
ImageView, it really depends on the kind of
control you want to have over the reproduction
of that image.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: If you want to have, be able
to use the different ImageView options for
scaling and positioning, you know then you
might want to base it on ImageView. You've
got a lot of options though there.
>>Joe Malin: Ok. Next question.
>>Trevor Johns: Actually before we move on,
>>Joe Malin: I'm sorry.
>>Trevor Johns: is anybody on the Hangout?
>>Joe Malin: Yeah, that's a good question.
>>Trevor Johns: No, ok, just a reminder, for
those of you who are watching live and have
just tuned in, feel free to join us live by
hopping on the Hangout and ask us whatever
Android-related questions you want. We'd love
to talk to you and we have plenty of open
spots. Otherwise feel free to go, join us
on our Moderator, where you can go and vote
on existing questions. So with that, back
to the Moderator queue.
>>Dan Galpin: Ok.
>>Joe Malin: Next question for Moderator,
"I'm implementing in-app billing. But when
I try to buy some item in the sample app I
don't get a response to my app and after a
few minutes I get an error 'Reason: Took too
long to deliver.' This bug was in known issues
for almost a year. Is there some update?"
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, I'll take that one, I
guess. [laughs] There's a lot of things at
play here.
>>Dan Galpin: Thanks Trevor.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, there's a lot of different
issues at play here, which is why that's been
in known issues for so long. We've fixed some
of them. Some of them are still outstanding
and there's been some new ones that cropped
up, cropped up recently and collectively all
these will just really affect the rate at
which users see these errors. The number of
users who see it, it's a small fraction of
users, but as a developer you're likely to
see, you know you're the one who's receiving
all these reports, so it's probably gonna
seem a little bit worse than it actually is.
I mean, it's definitely a serious issue. We
do take it seriously and we are working to
fix it.
>>Dan Galpin: So, so do
>>Trevor Johns: I can give you a little bit
of background for, oh, go ahead Dan.
>>Dan Galpin: So, do I, I had a question.
So he's trying to buy one of the sample items
in the sample application? Is that, is that?
>>Trevor Johns: No, this is an actual item,
so.
>>Dan Galpin: Some item in sample, that's
what I was trying to
>>Trevor Johns: Well, it's an actual item,
it's not the Android test sys queue
>>Dan Galpin: So the key thing to make sure
and you know is, is, is, you know the one
is that the application has been uploaded
to Google Play, that you're testing against
the same version the version that you've also
activated, not necessarily published, but
you've actually activated the version that's
been uploaded. There are a lot of things that
can cause errors.
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, it wouldn't cause that
error, though. It'll cause other errors.
>>Dan Galpin: It'll cause others.
>>Joe Malin: Ok, let's, let's go ahead Trevor,
let's hear what you were going to say.
>>Trevor Johns: So basically the important
thing to know here is usually when users get
that error it's one of two things. And the
most common one almost always is it just means
that the user has been flagged for additional
risk review. And we have roughly 30-second
time out for an order to complete, if it takes
longer than that Google Play will cancel the
order and the user will see that error. In
the background we're still performing our
risk review. If the user comes back and performs
that purchase later, our usual recommendation
is wait 24 hours. Sometimes it's a lot quicker,
sometimes it can take longer, it depends on
the individual circumstances, the order will
go through. Basically we have to go and vet
that user and make sure that the order isn't
fraudulent. We have a, we have a, a machine
learning based approach to this. We have a
lot of risk factors that go into the, into
our analysis, and we're actually pretty good
at detecting when orders are fraudulent, occasionally
there's some false positives and that's usually
what you see here. Now the other case is occasionally
there are some technical issues like you know
a credit card processor goes down or something
like that which can also cause that time out.
This is rare. But just so you know every now
and then if something like that does happen,
that can cause a temporary spike in these
error messages too. Our advice to users is
still the same. Just come back and try the
order a little bit later and it will probably,
and well it will go through if you try it
later, so that's our advice. Again, we do
take these errors really seriously. We handle
it on a case by case basis and if you do happen
to see it, feel free to open up a ticket with
Android Developer Support if you go to developer.android.com
at the bottom there's a contact link, a Contact
Us link, click that, open a ticket and provide
us your order IDs. The support team can go
and double check and see exactly why that
error happened and escalate it to our engineering
teams if it's something we haven't seen before.
>>Joe Malin: Ok.
>>Dan Galpin: Alright.
>>Joe Malin: That sounds like the right thing
to do. Next, we're still ok on Hangout, correct?
Alright, so next question for Moderator, "I
develop OpenGL (heavy in floating point).
Since the docs (see the link) say that float
and double are equivalent but double is bigger,
why do you recommend double anyway?" And there's
a link.
>>Dan Galpin: So we're really talking about
performance here. You know and so obviously
there are cases in which it's going to make
a difference in terms of performance to be
sending a lot less data is what happens if
you're sending a you know single precision
floating point, but there are times in which
having the additional fidelity of actually
having double precision is going to make things
look better. I think, I think that in general
what the doc is trying to point out is that
because of the architecture of modern CPUs,
you're really not going to lose a substantial
amount of performance really any by going
double most can execute double essentially
as quickly as they execute a single precision
floating point, you know a bit of arithmetic.
I think, the, the trickier part is whether
or not you're gonna be saturating memory band
width, you know, how much memory you're actually
taking up, all of these things. The other
thing of course is that you're actually getting
into OpenGL into using shaders on the other
hand there is an enormous difference between
using low, medium and high precision within
your shaders, so there is sort of, there is
a kind of secondary thing you're talking about,
OpenGL, and if you're going to be using low
precision in your shaders, it doesn't really
make sense to be feeding these things in with,
you know, double precision values necessarily.
But, but in, in, in general think you know
that the doc is just simply saying that filling
point is, is more expensive than integer math
and double precision doesn't really cost you
performance, it just costs you space, and
that's, that's I think that's really, I think
that's pretty clear. So.
>>Joe Malin: Ok. Alright.
>>Dan Galpin: Mmm hmm.
>>Joe Malin: Well I'd buy that answer.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Joe Malin: Next question on Moderator, "I've
seen a post of you on G." I'm not sure who
you is. "On G+ about new features of the ADT.
The most interesting feature for me was the
ability to preview a layout in different ways
(that is multiple languages) side by side.
Did I miss the ETA or was none present?"
>>Dan Galpin: I believe that was something,
was that something we showed off at, at Google
IO?
>>Trevor Johns: I actually can't remember
off the top of my head.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, I know. It's a, there
were, I know we showed off a whole bunch of
new features that were not yet available.
I think those are, those are coming you know,
you know, but we schedule, the way, the way
stuff works by the way with tools is we actually
develop the tools in the open. So at any time
if you don't see the feature there and we've
announced it, you can always go up and pull
the tools and build them and see whether it's
actually in the version that's currently buildable
on AOSP. The tools are really cool that way.
I mean, I've certainly told someone, "No,
the bug's been fixed, we haven't released
it, rolled out a new version of the tools,
but if you want, go grab that." So I don't
know what the state that code currently is
in, but you certainly can go and grab it and
see whether that can be enabled if it was
something we showed off at Google IO. But
I don't, I don't remember when we've talked
about the side by side previews.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, I can't remember the
ETA for that being released, but again, like
Dan said, it's all developed in the open you
can go ahead and you know take a look at the
code and see what the state of that is. On
top of that actually you could just check
the release notes on the Android Developer
website
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: and see what's actually in
the official releases.
>>Dan Galpin: Do we have someone on Hangout?
>>Dan Pham: Yeah we sure do.
>>Joe Malin: Ok, great. Fire away.
>>Dan Pham: Ohh, he just went dark.
>>Joe Malin: Hmm.
>>Dan Galpin: We've got dark
>>Trevor Johns: This is our, are you still
there audio wise?
>>Joe Malin: Hello? Hello?
>>Dan Pham: You still there?
>>Male #1: Yes I am. Yes I am.
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, we can just barely hear
you. Can we crank the volume?
>>Dan Pham: Yeah.
>>Joe Malin: Pump up the volume.
>>Male #1: Ok.
>>Dan Galpin: How's that?
>>Male #1: I was wondering, is it recommended
to keep the side drawer?
>>Trevor Johns: Hold on a sec.
>>Joe Malin: Hold on, hold on.
>>Trevor Johns: Is that coming out of the
headphones or the speakers?
>>Dan Pham: Yes, I don't know why.
>>Trevor Johns: Hmm.
>>Dan Pham: Want that.
>>Joe Malin: We are having a sound problem
again.
[sound of keys clicking]
>>Trevor Johns: I wouldn't worry about the
screen, I'd worry about the audio.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah. As far as I'm concerned
put the headphones on and tell us what he's
saying.
>>Dan Galpin: Are we back on?
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, I'm going to listen
to you on head phones.
>>Dan Galpin: Yes
>>Male #1: Is it recommended to keep the side
drawer
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, I think we just lost you
com, oh our Hangout's restarted. The question
I heard before it restarted was is it recommended
to keep the side drawer? I'm not sure what
else followed that, so, oh, we're coming back
online. Alright. You still there?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, yeah, sorry, we lost you
for a second there, could you repeat that
one more time?
>>Male #1: Is it recommended to keep the side
drawer constant, the pattern? And is there
any way to put it on the other side of the
screen?
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, so the question for everyone
else here on set, is it recommended to keep
the side drawer constant, the pattern constant,
or and also is it possible to move the side
drawer to the other side of the screen? So
I imagine the side drawer is like in Google+
or YouTube where you have a, a navigation
sidebar that pops out correct?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Trevor Johns: Ok, so yes, that is. Ok, so
I'm gonna go ahead and put the headphone,
actually I think I can keep this on, I look
sort of funny, but to answer your question
>>Dan Galpin: Not as funny as I look.
>>Joe Malin: I'm gonna lean down so I can
hear through his head.
>>Dan Galpin: Now, now we're all looking funny.
>>Trevor Johns: [laughs] So the side, the
side drawer pattern, it's definitely picked
up some popularity lately. Besides you know
Google+, YouTube's used it, I believe Facebook
uses it, Evernote uses it. Definitely a lot
of interest from developers. But it's not
part of the official Android UI guidelines
yet. It's basically something we're experimenting
with. If our design team decides that it's
actually something they like and they want
to promote, they'll add it to the Android
Design website and then it'll probably release
a sample code for it or at least code snippets,
but it's also entirely possible that they
decide that it's not the direction they want
to see Android going in right now. We don't
know. We're still waiting for official feedback
from them. So for that reason we don't have
much in the way of official guidance on how
to implement, implement this feature and for
that matter, when we get questions like can
we move it to the other side, we're not even
sure does that make sense, right? It might
make sense for thing maybe you have a left
handed user. I can see use cases where it
would make sense to have it on the other side.
From a technical perspective, we don't have
anything as part of the framework that would
do this for you. So it's technically possible
to place it on either side since you have
to write it from scratch.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, my feeling is that since
the overflow menu tends to sit on the other
side that it makes sense to have this sort
of drawer functionality opposite that, but
if there's a really compelling reason in your
UI and you know you think you think you're
breaking new ground, as I said there is no
official pattern on this. So you know I think
it ultimately comes down to does it serve
the user well? Now the user is actually you
know has a whole bunch of established applications
that are doing it the other way, so I think
you know it's certainly worth considering
you know whether or not it's worth changing
their expectations in this way. And that's
why whenever we deviate from the pattern,
you know I think from any one of our patterns,
whether it's one of the ones we've actually
established or one of the ones that is sort
of implied by the ecosystem, I think that
it's always good to look at the user and say
what is the user, what are the user's expectations
and, and why would, does it, you know why
does changing this make sense in terms of
their expectations?
>>Trevor Johns: Right. And you know like Dan
said, most of the time when you see a drawer
on the left, it's always on the left. On top
of that also your Up button is always on the
left.
>>Dan Galpin: Umm hmm.
>>Trevor Johns: And users read left to right.
So I think those are all really strong arguments
for most of the time placing that drawer,
that slide out drawer on the left.
>>Male #1: Ok. And yeah the only reason I
was wondering that was because I, because
some users like prefer having actions on the
right versus left and that was the only reason,
that was the only reason that I thought that
would make sense.
>>Trevor Johns: So once again for those here
on set, yeah basically the comment was you
know some users might prefer having action
on the right versus the left, so that would
be the reason why he was considering doing
that. You know I, I, I think that's, that's
something, it's definitely a valid point to
consider. But again you have to weigh it with
what the rest of the ecosystem's doing and
what's familiar to users.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: So it's a very fine line there,
there's not a 100% correct answer, but I'd
say like the 90% correct answer is that it
should usually be on the left.
>>Joe Malin: I was, yeah, I was gonna add
that Google TV for instance has a pattern
in which they replace the top action bar with
a side action bar and the side action bar
is on the left.
[high pitched sound heard]
>>Joe Malin: Just because TV displays have
a substantially different aspect ratio and
form than mobile device displays. And as I
said, they're the just bars on the left and
there's no option is usually provided
>>Trevor Johns: Assuming it's feedback, Dan.
Sorry.
>>Joe Malin: No option is usually provided
to move it to the right. I would say that
your specific questions about should it use
the same pattern? Yes. Should it stay on,
should there be an option to move it to the
right? I would say that it's not really necessary.
I mean it's, you know in general most users
don't need to have that sort of option, it's
preferable to have
>>Dan Galpin: I would say
>>Joe Malin: a consistent UI rather than one
that's infinitely malleable.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, I, you know, it's, I would
say play with it I mean you know and see what,
see what responses
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: If you're getting a lot of feedback
saying they want it on the other side, then
I would say go for it, you know 'cause you
know always ultimately you want to listen
to your users and that's something we kind
of believe here to a pretty strong degree.
But, but again you know I think that there's
a lot there's a lot of of prior art that actually
has it on the left hand side.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah.
>>Dan Galpin: And with Google TV a lot of
the reason we do we have it on the left is
because of navigation because
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Dan Galpin: you know we're, we're using
a four-way keypad and so it's easier to navigate
into that from the left than it is to navigate
up and then move through a bunch of options,
so I think that was, that was a lot of the
design decision around that as well.
>>Male #1: Alright. Thank you.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah, you're welcome. Thank you
for calling in.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so we have about
two minutes left it looks like.
>>Joe Malin: Ok.
>>Trevor Johns: And I don't think anyone is
waiting on Hangouts, so let's go ahead
>>Joe Malin: Wanna try on this
>>Trevor Johns: and take one last question.
>>Joe Malin: "Could you recap my question
on the missing shortcut docs last week? Couldn't
hear most of your answer due to static. My
main use case is to replicate the place on
home screen menu item in the detail view of
the people app. Is this possible with App
Widget?" I think this is where we discovered
that it wasn't really an app widget, it was
a shortcut.
>>Trevor Johns: That's correct. And the docs
were missing for those.
>>Joe Malin: Ahh.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, and as somebody who
works with the docs, do you wanna take this
one?
>>Joe Malin: Yes, the only thing that we can
do at this point is you know have you file
a bug to say we need documentation on this.
Other than that, you know I can take it back
to the documentation team and say we need
more documentation on this, but that looks
like it was a feature that was mostly exploited
by the People App because they knew something
about how the thing works and they could go
directly to the
[high-pitched beeping]
>>Joe Malin: engineers. And other than that
I'm not sure that there's anything else that
we could do.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, the People App is open
source though. So, I always hate
>>Joe Malin: That's true, I didn't think about
that.
>>Trevor Johns: yeah, I always hate like sending
people off to the, say go look at the source
when there's other options available, but
in this case there really isn't much else
you can do at the moment, so go to source.android.com
and you can check out the Android source tree.
It's a bit large, but you can take a look
at the People's App and see how they implement
this and that's probably the best resource
you have available at the moment.
>>Joe Malin: Right. Yep. I would agree with
that at this point.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright and I think we're
out of time.
>>Joe Malin: Yes, it's, yeah pretty much.
>>Dan Galpin: Alright.
[beep, beep]
>>Dan Pham: That's it, guys.
>>Trevor Johns: Yep, there it is,
>>Joe Malin: There's the tone.
>>Dan Galpin: Thank you for joining us.
>>Trevor Johns: So again for those of you
who are joining us for the first time, we
are on every Wednesday at 2 p.m. Pacific.
We love to answer your questions. You can
submit them ahead of time on our Moderator
queue –vote them up--or join us live and
we'll see you next week, Wednesday, 2 p.m.
>>Joe Malin: Great. Until then.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright. See you everyone.
>>Joe Malin: Wrong hand.